salut bonjour aujourd'hui ce casse tête
je ne vais pas le faire tout seul je le
faire avec
avec l'autre comme mollet salut les gars
ben ce qu'ils te connaissent pas c'est
toi qui montre les vidéos qui réalise
les vidéos la plupart du temps dans 99 %
litres d'eau enchanté peuvent pas très
bon mais en même temps personne n'a dit
qu'il peut être répond c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour à un
casse tête dont je connais pas le nom
parce que c'est en allemand et je suis
même pas sûre que ce moment du casse
tête mais plutôt une indication en fait
grosso modo c'est un difficultés
extrêmes
quand je les achetais il y avait
remarqué qu'il ya un cadenas à
l'intérieur mais qu'il faut juste ouvrir
la boite c'est le but du jeu ok c'est
toi qui t'y cole et puis moi je
réfléchis en même temps seulement comme
si c'est moi qui commande ce qui te
colle donc je fais la phase
d'exploration est comme des viticole
mais les tigres qui colle ok tu ne
supportes fait de ce que tu veux ce fait
tous que ce si jamais vous voulez voir
la version non coupée de cette
résolution c'est sur la chaîne
secondaire fabien aventis moteur pantone
kidon qui se trouve dans la description
bien sûr le castel se trouvait à la
description comme ça je vous le redis
répu et je fais un concours instagram
pour le gagner 6 louvre
sinon on refait une vidéo avec
l'installer dans la description et ya du
contenu gay rigolo je pense je le sens
je le sais mais je le suis je pense que
je vais réussir le métis l'aragon d'asie
c'est parti loïc plan badass du casse
tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah comme comme on sait bien faire
moi je regarderai où je les ai monté
j'étais là son exploration alors ça on
sent que celle du jeu passion ne pas ta
grosse tête dans le cade sinon l'oeil
qui gueule après dedans y'a rien ça ça
ne bouge pas ça il ya une fente jamais
peut-être on peut voir dedans et on voit
voile est très léger en grosse le
ressort du tout est apte rocha quelque
chose de non magistrats à ce que le saas
est accrocheur mon pain pour excuse moi
je veux pas non mais parce que j'étais
en train de faire une fausse déclaration
exploit exploit ce qu'il aurait déjà
parlé fabien de la fois où tu as
construit un catenaccio jamais je n'ai
jamais parlé de ça j'ai acheté un
casse-tête des casse têtes qu'on peut
construire soi même et c'est super cool
c'est en 3d et tout c'est chaud je me
convaincs de temps à le monter je t'ai
mis 12 heures 43 eur ouais c'est ça donc
on a tout filmé heures c'était pour
faire la vidéo le concept de la vidéo
c'est qu'après loïc devait le résoudre
avec fanny était en fait vous n'avez
jamais essayé de résoudre pourquoi parce
que comme moi même j'ai essayé de le
résultat me suis aperçu que j'avais du
bois dans la construction parce que
vraiment les trucs ne marchait pas entre
en fait j'ai remarqué qu'il fallait gré
c'est un peu des trucs avec un peu de
boixe et tout est gelé pas fait en
dehors mais ça va du coup vraiment trois
heures sur une petite table au milieu
type télé rage de sally page et
l'éruption que généreux ait eu à faire
alors pour l'instant mon peuple
j'imagine c'est tout bête mais on peut
pas juste l'enlever en maintenant
j'avais pensé j'avais j'ai vécu du coup
j'étais en effet le fait de passer ça
c'est le premier truc auquel tu as pensé
quoi
mais ce que tu as dit alors et c'est pas
qu'on le fait que peut-être ça est
accroché à quelque chose demain et que
si on arrive à faire un
un truc axa décroche encore parce qu'en
fait ce qui bloque l'assesseur jeu mais
en même temps ça fait un mouvement qui
m'a intéressé toile non je te dit pas
lequel pour l'instant je pas de spoil
on n'est pas indépendante immensee on
antilles mais un mais tu gardes les
informations pour toi en fait je pense
depuis le départ c'est aussi pour ça que
tu es invité sur ce casse tête j'ai une
idée 1 6t des bonnes ça veut dire qu'il
ya deux trois étapes max pour l'ouvrir
si un truc qui me démangent grave
affaire avec leurs armes
vous avez remarqué que les quatre
casse-tête précédent et soulage j'avais
cette chemise c'est pas du tout que en
fait on a toujours nié sa survie voilà
dix jours jours je jour jolie oui on a
tous tournés d'un coup je vous l'avais
dit dans la vidéo avec je sais plus quel
casse-tête
moi j'ai parti retourner au québec donc
en fait on tournait les casse-têtes bas
depuis 10 heures ce matin il mais quelle
heure loïc 18h05 aucune batterie qui
nous a lâché ça fait 8h50 qu'on fait du
cast est excellente a fini en touche
mais carrément alors moi je pense avoir
exploré voit des trucs que je fais quand
j'ai des trucs comme ça
gc ca j'essaie de tourner ça ça mène pas
grand chose ça même pas grand chose
d'assez d'appuyer sur tout ce qui appuya
bhl oui quand on s'est remis ça se bouge
ça sert bien c'est que ça passe au
travers de la non ça c'est ça le truc
qu'on voit alors oui on voit une barre
là dans la fonte
donc ça c'est donc ça veut dire que
l'anneau en plus si sera retenu mon mais
sans s'en fout quoi ça c'est un beau
local non tout se passe là un bon gars
si on arrive à attirer ça ça rigolo
parce que au lieu d'avoir un truc à
digital code et tout c'est ça qui bloque
taboth ça ça je trouve ça hyper rigolo
je le trouve très très cool bien dans la
description je me dis si on arrive à le
virer du coup là nos tombes et par sept
fentes sais je cherche toujours à voir
ce qui bloque qu'est ce qui bloque c'est
juste là nous on fait rien j'ai pas
l'impression que ça ça bloque quoi que
ce soit j'ai envie de leur faire voir
une story tu entends tu passais mon tél
moi je progresse sortie après bah
écoutez petit moment de divertissement
on vous mêlez story qu'on est con qu'on
a fait aujourd'hui sur mon instinct et
celui de loïc et du coup vous pouvez les
voir maintenant et vous abonner à loïc
est à moi ensuite c'est parti
vous ne trouvez pas ça bizarre mais
jamais vu loïc et fabien dans la même
pièce
coïncidence mais je ne crois pas c'est
bien ça t'amuse vous connaissez la
blague des 68 étudiants merci est ce que
vous connaissez la blague des 68 fabien
c'est un petit peu relou casque il ya
loïc je vous disais l'histoire des 68
étudiants
oui fabien caméra le dernier tournage
comme ça prendra fini c'est mieux et on
est de retour aux gars je vais faire
comme les chaînes qui ornent les
chiennes les chaînes c'est un anneau
complet tu penses plus mauvais pictures
ici et bien se passer
qu'est ce que tu fais rien du tout rien
du tout méfait car ici ça ça suppose
images ont fait je crois tu parles
l'un d'eux rien de la tête il n'était
pas si mal le monde ça fait combien de
temps qu'on met à mais c'est toi qui l'a
prise j'étais convaincu [ __ ] j'avais
appelé à mx m
c'est maintenant bon week lagarde y bat
ans ça va c'est pas moi je passe pas des
journées à faire des cassettes pas bien
tu te fiches
ça fait 8 heures 50 confus du coeur
stone qui peut passer ça comme ça je
vais pour tdc pour donner un coup de
main
trop bien parce que techniquement donc
c'est un cercle à l'intérieur attend il
faut que je t'aide à réfléchir
merci pour moi c'est donc un cercle
intérieur complet est ce que tu penses
que si je fais tu penses que peut-être
on peut faire tourner l'anneau et qu' il
ya un moment dans la noyer une encoche
c'est le premier truc que j'aurais fait
en boîte après on peu de repères sur la
note
ouais carrément donc c'est pas ça ok
mais là et pas un peu tordu sa ou ses
juges font la nique et peut-être un peu
ni gaming et mais j'ai pas que tu la
vois à regarde à droite tu regardes pas
un nom je fais ça et du coup je pense
que c'est la bonne voie c'est la bonne
voie profitez-en si vous voulez pour
vous abonner à cette chaîne via ce
bouton d'abonnement caché dans le cou de
loïc abonnez-vous en masse à sa gratte
est à banon mais abonnez-vous je le dis
plus en fin de vidéo je sais pas si vous
avez fait gars du sud et ses raquettes
ouais mais comment tu aimes j'ai trop
réussi ce jeune homme est ce que tu sais
pas comment ceux ci a donc on avait
raison ah oui d'accord c'est un peu à
jour y attend on va le refaire mais je
vais me remettre dans sa config initial
et du coup maintenant tu sais que c'est
possible mais tu sais pas bien comment
ils ont retenu comme ça juste en
regardant quoi oui est-ce que tu as
remarqué dans les casses têtes
souvent quand je bloque je m'arrête et
je le regarde je vous apporte c'est pas
bien mais c'est ce qui me permet
d'arrêter de fumer non souvent je
regarde et après je me fais tout des
essais dans ma tête et après je dis est
peut-être un peu comme sherlock dans la
série sherlock
mais c'est très smart c'est très
intelligent comme système
en fait c'est le principe de faire un
avec des cordes c'est ça que je me suis
dit moi ouais c'est ce que je regarde je
te fais voir qu'en faire mieux avec des
cordes ont fait caca claque pour que la
corde surprise dans l'anneau par exemple
ouais donc là le premier truc que j'ai
fait c'est que ça je l'inversé ah
c'était ça ce bruit ouais ok et du coup
là si je fais là bas je peux aller au
bout ouais et donc le lever et donc le
sortir c'est cool ou pas je crois que
c'est quand même moi qu'il est ouvert
bien sûr regardez là en fait ça rentre
parce que c'est contre intuitif
là ça rentre ici je fais comme pour une
vis quand ça va rentrer je vais tourner
un petit peu peur commence à suivre lax
tac
donc là il a suivi lac se maintenant il
en est ici mais on voit bien que si je
continue en fait là je le sors d'accord
je le mets tac l'âge avance un petit peu
n'est pas réellement pris il est plutôt
entre les mind et là je le tourne un
coup jacques et là il est complètement
pris là ont pu vous faire comme comme
samedi
et bien c'est cool c'est une affaire
rondement menée ou est-ce qu'on peut le
gagner sur instagram
ou est-ce qu'on peut la voir la vidéo
sans montage sur la chaîne secondaire ou
est ce qu'on peut trouver tout ça pour
la description c'est que casse tête si
vous voulez le lia à très bientôt merci
de nous avoir regardé
elle était bien oui